when you're training in a swimming pool
various technology if it can kind of
count how fast you're swimming all that
technology works one lymph at a time so
it knows that you get to the end of a
length and it can say okay you've swum
25 more meters but actually when you're
when you're actually training what
people are really interested in what you
often get in if you're coached is people
breaking down the length in two
different sets over the approach to a
turn at the end the breakout when you
come out of a turn and the bit in the
middle when you're just swimming when
you're outside you're using your
smartphone to find where you are GPS is
great it tells you exactly where you are
but then you go inside and most of the
time it just doesn't work and various
people have used kind of indoor
navigation technologies which are
designed to sense things about the
building you're in to find out where you
are without using GPS and one of the
things that they've used is some
anomalies in the Earth's magnetic field
which are caused by the structure of a
building you're in typically think your
smartphone has a compass in it but what
your smartphone actually has is called a
magnetometer what that does is that
measures for magnetic field surrounding
the smartphone in three axes so an x y&z
axis and one piece of information you
can get out of that is what is the
direction of that vector that you get
out of that and that's actually that is
the compass directions make its your
compass but as well as that it's a
vector it has a direction it also has a
magnitude so the magnitude that it gives
you is what if you're outside that
magnitude is the magnitude of the
Earth's magnetic field at that point
which stays constant for a large
distance once you get inside that's
really affected by anything that's large
a metal or any electrical equipment
which is near you so if I walk through a
massive skyscraper with a big steel
frame then it's going to be putting and
what a different direction possibly on
the vector magnitude typically it won't
get so it won't get so bad that the
compass completely the compass direction
gets completely destroyed if you're
walking along a corridor in a skyscraper
each time you go past an upright beam
you often see a kind of big increase in
the magnitude at that point looking at a
swimming pool what swimming pool is it's
a big rectangular hole here here here
here and here this is all reinforced
concrete reinforced concrete is concrete
with metal bars in it your swimming pool
is surrounded by great big lumps of
metal all of these affect how the
magnetic field is perturbed so each time
you get close to one of these lumps of
metal the magnitude of a magnetic field
will change and if you look at swimming
pool from the side typically that will
start a deep end and it'll go up slowly
and then the shallow end fell typically
be a steep bit and then an almost flat
shallow end at the bottom you've got
more big lumps of metal and you always
swimming on the top or at least we're
assuming you're always forming on the
top so here you are on the top let the
deep end you are this far you're quite a
long way away from this metal so this
metal isn't perturbing you the magnetic
field too much and at the shallow end
you're really quite close so it's a much
bigger effect this effect is very much
linear in the direction you swimming so
you swim up and down the pool because
this height only changes along the pool
if you swim up and down the pool here or
you swim up and down the pool here or
here the way in which it changes is
pretty much the same because you're
always at this point this point this
point at this point you always this
distance away and this point this point
at this point you're always much closer
you can take this and you can measure
the magnetic field strength this graph
here I'm pointing at this shows a
magnetic field measured along the pool
like and regularly swimmer this is the
shallow end and as you go along with
Paul you can see it kind of has a kind
of characteristic change this change in
magnitude actually happens as you swim
along with Paul and I've kind of
demonstrated that the magnetic field is
perturbed by the shape of a swimming
pool and that the way that happens
changes as you go along reporter as you
swim up and down how do you go from that
to actually getting position of a
swimmer out it's unlikely people were
lots of people will go swimming with
smartphones at the moment but if they do
want to
is a lot of kind of commercial equipment
out there for doing so and them so I've
got the waterproof case of a smartphone
here and I've just got a standard sort
of bag for it and I just take that and
strap it so into some small of my back
there that keeps it in the same place on
my back and it's waterproof I've swum
for a good few hours with this and other
people is wrong with it you wouldn't
want to train every day with a
smartphone strapped on your back but if
you're if you're going down to a
training session it's not actually that
different you can still swim fine as
long as it's kind of tightly attached to
you the first thing I did with this is I
stuck a phone on my back recorded
delayed of data whilst I was just
kicking on my front and lying still am
at looked grey and they fought okay it
looked just like these graphs and I
thought okay that's great I am yeah end
of project but then when you actually
swim so I've got some video here of me
swimming and you can see as I swim my
whole body actually rotates from side to
side so it says um as you kind of pull
you rotate your whole body twists about
50 to 60 degrees and when you look at
the magnetometer readings you get
something that looks like this graph
here you can see here it still got the
same basic shape that I showed in
previous graph but every time I move
from left to right is a great big jump
up and jump down these magnetometers
have errors one of the big errors in
them is that the strength form a record
on each axis isn't really very accurate
and a different axes are differently
accurate as you rotate the magnitude is
which you're making from the vector is
coming from different parts of a vector
so if the X is strong my as you rotate
to one side then the X kind of dominates
and as you come back the other way it
goes back down again previous work on
magnetic navigations all been indoor
navigation and they're assuming that
people will not move their phone they're
not you know wave their phone like this
while they're walking along they're
assuming that people will be walking
looking at a phone like that in some
projects very assuming it's hanging
around your neck search in a very
constant kind of orientation Paul
situation is at
surprisingly hard to collect data from
what I actually did is them I've got an
algorithm for fixing this which is it
looks at each of the x y&z and it says
what would happen if these were if this
one was off by nine point five percent
example because the key thing that we
know is the real profile on this graph
moves quite select changes quite slowly
in comparison to the error which is on
this graph which goes up and down quite
quickly so you're trying to remove this
error and you know what's causing that
error so what you're looking for is a
way to change for weightings of each
axis so that this graph is as smooth as
possible so we've put a lot of
technology now and we're looking at kind
of creating interactive systems that
respond to how people are swimming if
you're an elite swimmer you have access
to an awful lot of technology which will
give you in some cases it will even give
you kind of feedback at the end of each
length your coach can kind of see you a
data as to exactly how you swam on that
length but for a normal swimmer there's
nothing so it can give you any kind of
feedback and particularly if you're not
coached at all being able to get some
kind of real-time feedback on how your
swimming is going I think that could be
a real kind of complete game changer for
sort of Amateur swimmers
yes that a runner might actually be in
this video they have been seasoned what
we can do with this is basically pull
out a collection of video fragments some
of which we know the runner is
explicitly in because they've been seen
and tank and some word that we think
they might be yum yum they're going to
never see that no that's mine now let's
go back into the Machine again think
about again